معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي امين ما الذي رشح حتى الان حول هذه
المباحثات التي يجريها بلينكن في
اسرائيل نعم سهام هذه اللقاءات
والاجتماعات ما زالت متواصله بين بلينكن
والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين في هذه الاثناء
هو يجري لقاء مغلقا مع الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق هيرتسوغ وقبل هذا اللقاء كانت هناك
تصريحات
بروتوكوليا اصدر اصدرت عن او صدرت عن
بلينكن قال فيها بان الفتره الراهنه او
المرحله الحاليه هي للتركيز على مساله
اعاده المختطفين بحسب قوله الاسرائيليين
في قطاع غزه وقال بان هناك امل في مستقبل
واعد بحسب قوله يتم فيه دمج او اندماج
اسرائيل في الشرق الاوسط و ويلبي مخاوفها
الامنيه او يبدد مخاوفها الامنيه بالاحرى
اضافه الى انه يلبي مطامح الشعب الفلسطيني
هذه التصريحات طبعا جاءت بعد ان انهى
بلينكن لقاء سابقا برئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو هذا اللقاء الذي وصفه مكتب رئيس
الوزراء بانه كان طويلا ومعمق وتلى هذا
اللقاء لقاء اخر موسع حضره كل من رئيسي
جهاز الشباب وايضا المصد اضافه الى وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ورئيس هيئه الاركان
وايضا
رئيس المجلس القومي
الاسرائيلي بعد ذلك سيتوجه نتنياهو من
القدس الى رام الله للقاء الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس على ان يعود مساء
الى تل ابيب
وستكون هناك او سيكون مؤتمر صحفي على
الاحرى سيكون يتطرق لكل كل تلك اللقاءات
التي جمعته بالمسؤولين الاسرائيليين على
طوال هذا اليوم كان هناك ايضا لقاء بين
نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع يوف جالانت مباشره
بعد لقائه برئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
القناه الثان ع الاسرائيليه ونقلا عن مكتب
رئيس الوزراء قالت بان نتنياهو رفض مقترحا
وطلبا ل بلينكن من اجل عقد لقاء منفرد مع
رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي وهذا ربما وجه من
اوجه الخلاف بين اداره الرئيس الامريكي
بايدن وايضا اداره نتنياهو طبعا هناك
انباء عن ان رد حركه حماس الذي تلقته
اسرائيل امس عبر الوسيط القطري ويتم الان
بحثه يلقى في احد او في بعض جوانبه رفضا
مطلقا من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه فيما
هناك نقاط وبحسب مسؤول كبير اسرائيلي نقلا
عن القناه الثان ع الاسرائيليه يمكن البحث
فيه ودراسته وقبل قليل فقط اعلن على ان
نتنياهو
سيستبدل
ل بلينكن بعقد مؤتمر صحفي في القدس وذلك
للمره الاولى منذ بدايه هذه الحرب سيتطرق
فيه لرد حركه حماس ووجهه نظر الاسرائيليه
وايضا كيف سيتبلور الرد الاسرائيلي على
ذلك المقترح هذه الزياره وهذه اللقاءات
طبعا تجري في اجواء مشحونه بحكم ان
هناك اختلاف داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بشان الشكل النهائي لاي صفقه لتبادل الاسر
مع حركه حماس او اي هدنه مستقبليه وايضا
هناك خلافات واضحه بين اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن والحكومه الاسرائيليه
حتى نتنياهو نفسه قبل ايام كان قدع رف
بوجود هذه الخلافات امين درغامي مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من تل ابيب شكرا لك